so why do you think greyscale bitcoin
trust is not allowed to do it
great to be back thanks for having me on
charles so i think it's very simple i
don't think it's an issue specifically
with greyscale because around four to
five um bitcoin sport acs has been
rejected in the last few months i think
it comes down to the fact that gary
ginsler just thinks it's too risky for
investors with regards to greyscale
bitcoin trust he thinks that they
haven't done enough to prevent against
manipulation and fraud but i think this
is slightly ridiculous because they have
of course um approved the futures etf
which actually in my opinion is a lot
riskier for investors just given the
complexity um of that financial
instrument but ultimately this is what
it comes down to the if they do approve
a bitcoin spot etf that will spark the
next bull market regardless of the
liquidations and everything that we're
seeing right now in the selling pressure
that was sparked the nice bull market
and they need to figure out how they can
take a piece of the pie and they haven't
yet done that they haven't yet
implemented enough regulation in order
to take a piece of the pie but they
better hurry up to us because if they
don't we've got canada australia and
parts of europe which is really just
beating america right now you know it's
so amazing to me that uh you know that
the sec is saying okay that would be
their answer we're trying to protect
investors uh you know i can name a
gazillion stocks over the last 20 years
they did they provided little to no uh
protection about and a number of
investments including all the times wall
street almost blew up the entire world
where they agreed and an unbridled greed
and knowing that they would be bailed
out so i find it to be completely
irresponsible and unfair and i'm i tend
to agree with you something is going on
behind the scenes to slow this whole
thing down in fact there's a report that
was commissioned by the pentagon i saw
it yesterday it blew my mind they're
saying that blockchain is is not
decentralized that it's vulnerable to
attacks and they say the software is
outdated does that mean the whole
premise is outdated that it's no good
oh well what they're talking about is no
good because it's completely incorrect
of course we know there's over 20 000
different cryptocurrencies and bitcoin
is completely different to all the other
assets cryptocurrencies come in many
different um shapes and sizes if you
like some are totally centralized some
are bc backed some of the networks go
down bitcoin is totally different
because it is entirely decentralized
there is no ceo there was no pre-miners
so for some unknown reason they're
really lacking a lot of nuance there and
it's very reductionist i think it's
absolutely false and as we know bitcoin
is in a league of its own it's nothing
like the others like i said vc backed
they don't even pretend to be
decentralized bitcoin is decentralized
no ceo and that is really important that
distinction is essential so thank you
for allowing me to er to make that
distinction hey listen when the pentagon
uh you know says it's not you know when
you start to get the pentagon involved
you do scratch your head yeah i got to
tell you it does seem to me the
establishment kind of putting up these
speed bumps uh so that the federal
reserve maybe could get its own central
bank currency in place now you say that
the cbd uh the central bank the
decentralized currencies that the
ultimate form of
authoritarianism what do you mean by
that
that is correct so central bank digital
currencies are um basically
cryptocurrencies because they're on
blockchain technology but they're
dangerous because they'll be highly
programmable so if for whatever reason
you don't support the current thing and
you don't get either vaccinated or
whatever it is that money can be
programmed to work against you so during
the height of and the pandemic many
people who are unvaccinated weren't
allowed to go in certain shops so
instead of doing that with a central
bank digital currency because it's
programmable that level of
discrimination becomes far more
efficient and also if we look at the the
uh economics of this during times of um
economic uncertainty um central banks
like to print more money in order to
stimulate the economy they need that
money to change hands but we could get
to a point where because this central
bank digital currency is programmable
and that money could essentially expire
so the central bank will say to you we
need you to spend the money so if you
don't spend let's say 10 of what you
have in your bank account in the next
three months that money is going to
expire that's your hard money that you
that you've earned is going to expire
but of course charles they're doing it
to protect you so they can stimulate the
economy very dangerous central bank
digital currencies are more efficient
enslavement machines